if you've ever been into the thing that
is often called world music or
especially if you were around in the
late 80s or early 90s you would have
undoubtedly been exposed to people like
the famous kawali singer nusrat fatherly
khan
he is a very good example of what is
often termed sufi music and while many
have heard this kind of music before few
are aware of its history development and
its use in mystical practices we have
arrived at one of my main fields of
study and interest so let's talk about
the music of the sufis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've already explored the general
history and development of music in the
islamic world in previous episodes a
deep and highly developed tradition of
diverse forms and expressions and one of
the most important and central factors
in the development and maintenance of
islamic music have been the sufis the
muslims who have heavily emphasized
practices of inner purification known as
tasawolf to reach intimacy with god what
is often termed islamic mysticism
through their frequent use of music as
an important part of these practices
sufis have both legitimized and helped
carry forward music in the islamic world
in ways that still inspire today many of
us have of course seen and perhaps even
experienced the famous whirling
dervishes of the mev levy order which is
a particular form of expression of the
music-infused sufi rituals that have
been so central to its history when we
talk about sufi music as such we are
usually talking specifically about the
devotional practice called sama an
arabic word that literally means
audition or listening and in which sufis
in history and today have engaged in
listening to poetry or music as an
essential spiritual practice sometimes
often involving movements of the body or
dance broadly defined
in this episode we'll be defining sufi
music a little more broadly the practice
and ritual oriented music will be the
bulk of the discussion of course but we
will also include more contemporary art
music that includes
sufi themes as part of this wider
category of sufi music in any case
sufism or tasawolf in arabic is a word
that is used broadly to refer to all
kinds of islamic mysticism today even if
it was originally used to denote a
specific group of renuncians in 9th and
10th century baghdad and this more broad
use of the word is what we will be
employing in this episode as well we'll
leave a more complex discussion about
the varieties of early islamic mysticism
for a future episode but from the very
earliest period of sufism and islam
generally music was being used as an
important practice for spiritual
development
aside from the regular practices and
rituals that all muslims performed like
the daily prayers etc sufis developed
further ways to deepen their
relationship to the quranic message the
sunnah of the prophet muhammad and with
god the most universal of these
practices is that one will gather for
hadra or literally gathering and perform
vikr or remembrance in viktor sufis will
often chant the islamic proclamation of
faith
or the different names of god in a
repeated fashion and often for long
periods of time
this chanting can sometimes be
accompanied by percussion instruments so
those you can see that the lines between
this vikar and that other kind of ritual
sama aren't always crystal clear what is
clear is that sama or audition the act
of listening as an important spiritual
practice was present from the earliest
days of sufism
in the circle of baghdad the original
sufis so to say that by important
figures like junaid and abul hussain and
nuri we know that these ecstatic musical
gatherings took place as well as in
other places around the islamic world
also even earlier in history in the 8th
century the very earliest periods this
kind of practice seems to have been very
common sama as opposed to regular zikr
was based around the power of auditory
experience it has almost always revolved
primarily around the melodic recitation
of devotional poetry but has often been
accompanied by musical instruments of
various sorts
in sessions of sama the practitioners
will also sometimes induce movements of
the body to increase its effects now
important to remember here is that while
sama has been a important and widespread
practice in the history of sufism not
all sufi has partaken it there have been
many sufis in history that have been
very critical of sama or listening to
music in various forms criticizing it as
a corruption that has no place in the
religion while others have seen it as an
essential part of spiritual practices in
later periods when sufism developed into
the different orders there were some
orders that placed a major emphasis on
sama and music like the mev levy order
or the chishtia
while other orders are much more
reluctant to use it like the
nakshpandiya for example we'll return to
this topic a little bit later but we
should remember that sufism just like
islam generally is diverse and there is
a multitude and diversity of opinions
and attitudes towards the devotional
listening to music but from the earliest
days of its developments and until today
sama in its various forms have been a
very popular and important part of sufi
practices and there are two different
ways in which one can view the power and
meaning of this ritual number one the
practical side that is how sama is
performed and what effect it has on the
practitioner and number two the
theoretical side that is how do the
sufis imagine that music and sound and
its effects can be placed within a
metaphysical and cosmological framework
we will explore both of these
perspectives to fully understand the
vast topic of sufi music some of you may
be thinking hold on philip doesn't islam
forbid music it is true that many
muslims in history and today have
considered music forbidden that you know
something that cannot be denied of
course but what is also true is that
many others have considered completely
permissible and in various circumstances
now for a more full discussion about the
legal status of music in the islamic
world and the islamic religion i suggest
you watch some of my earlier episodes
about music in the islamic world because
i cover that topic more deeply there but
many of the sufis certainly didn't
consider it forbidden especially not
when it was used for religious purposes
and in order to help the practitioners
strengthen his relationship to god this
is why we see some of the most important
early sufi writers like saraj abu tala
belmeki and kushayri defending the
practice of listening to music in sufi
gatherings and this also gives us a good
look into the way that sama was
practiced and conceptualized in early
sufism in his very significant research
the epistle of kosairi on the science of
sufism the scholar abu qasim al-quri
writes that quote know that listening to
music is permissible when it means the
perception of beautiful sounds and
pleasant melodies when the listener does
not intend anything that is prohibited
when he does not listen to anything that
is condemned by the divine law when he
allows no free reign to his passions and
is not seduced by the amusement that
resides in it and that quote they the
soupies say listening to music is a
delicious nourishment for the spirits of
divine gnostics
abu nasser saraj argues in his kitab
lumaf the subwoof that quote the prophet
said wisdom is sometimes to be found in
poetry since poetry may be recited there
is no objection to reciting it with
musical notes and melodies and with an
agreeable intonation various divines and
lawyers have pronounced in favor of
audition for example malik and anas it
is well known that malik and the people
of medina did not dislike audition shafi
was of the same opinion and we find
similar arguments in other formative
works of sufism like apothemaki's
kuttalkulub and the works of assolami
what these sufi writers were trying to
do was not only to argue for its total
compatibility with islam and its law by
showing through hadith reports how the
prophet and his companions approved of
sama or that most of the founders of the
law schools didn't consider music
prohibited as such but also to show in
what way the sama was an essential
sometimes even necessary parts of
mystical practice and the path to
spiritual realization as well as what
rules were required for it to be
considered legitimate from these writers
as well as other sources we get an idea
of the power and purpose of sama
sessions we hear stories of various
sufis like abdul nun mistri abu suleiman
adarani and others and how they would
fall into bouts of ecstasy faint and
other very dramatic things as a result
of hearing beautiful sounds and melodies
quote a group of sufis used to gather at
the house of al-hasan al-qasas they were
accompanied by singers whose singing
made them ecstatic
or even more dramatically quote
related
entered baghdad local sufis gathered
around him among them was a singer
the sufis asked dul nunn's permission to
have him the singer perform something
for them he gave them his permission and
the singer began to recite he recites
some lines of poetry and on hearing this
velnun stood up and fell on his face
blood streaming from his forehead onto
the ground
then one of the sufis also stood up and
displayed ecstatic behavior as already
mentioned and as the name suggests sama
revolves around listening
in these sessions one would listen to
beautiful words or melodies it could be
as simple as the recitation of the quran
but more often it involved devotional
sufi poetry poetry praising the prophet
muhammad or talking about one's love or
intimacy with god
this experience of listening was further
enhanced by the accompaniment of musical
instruments of varying sorts as well as
different forms of dancing
jean during defined it as such quote
sama which literally means audition
denotes in the sufi tradition spiritual
listening and more particularly
listening to music with the aim of
reaching a state of grace or ecstasy or
more simply with the aim of meditating
or plunging into oneself or as the sufi
say to nourish the soul it thus operates
in a mystical concert of spiritual
listening to music and songs in a more
or less ritualized form this act of
listening is thought to help the
practitioner evolve spiritually and in
the most exalted situations help him or
her enter a state of spiritual ecstasy
or perhaps even union with god i think
we've all experienced the incredible
power that music can have on our
emotions we've heard music that can make
us sad music that makes us happy that
makes us contemplative
some of us maybe have even experienced
music that can take us completely out of
our regular awareness or consciousness
and take us to some other sometimes even
ecstatic state
this power of music was not lost on
people in
in the ancient times or in medieval
times including of course the muslims
this is why the sufis saw it as such a
important and useful tool for spiritual
development and of course also why the
enemies of music saw it as such a danger
to society and to people it was a very
good tool for helping the practitioner
enter the state of wajd or ecstasy to
help orient the heart towards god
consciousness and to some even induce
the highest form of spiritual experience
and union
again in the epistle of khoshairi quote
someone inquired of abu yakub and
about listening to music he answered
this is a state that brings about the
return to the divine mysteries through
the burning of one's self
beautiful music and possibly the words
of poetry that accompanies it can move
you towards and induce the state of
self-annihilation or fana so sought
after by sufis a state when the ego
becomes effaced in the reality of god
who is realized to be the only thing
existing in the earliest period the
practice of sama does not seem to have
been as structured or ritualized as it
would become in later periods we do know
that gatherings took place as i just
described but not so much about what
they would have been like
as mentioned we know that the early
soupies would gather formally and take
part in musical auditions and many
sources suggest that both men and women
were involved and that sometimes even
women could lead these sessions and sama
as such could also be a very spontaneous
thing it didn't have to be in a
ritualized setting to have effects there
are many stories of sufis who are just
walking along the street and suddenly
hear a beautiful sound
maybe someone singing or reciting verses
of poetry and immediately just following
into an ecstatic state sometimes
fainting and very dramatic such things
kenneth s avery writes quote a chance
hearing of words song or poetry in a
crowded place the cry of a street vendor
or a misheard sound or utterance could
also act as a powerful trigger for
altered state experiences
these ecstatic states or outhaul of
ecstasy watched was also often
associated with certain behaviors as you
can tell
the stories about sufis ripping their
clothes yelling and fainting showcase
how powerful these altered states could
be
this was another controversial point and
there were often variations of opinions
about how one should approach them
sometimes scholars have talked about a
sober kind of sufism associated with
figures like junaid and later al-qazali
and a quantum quote intoxicated form of
sufism more associated with figures like
abu yazid al-bistami
while this dichotomy is somewhat
simplifying it does hint at the
different attitudes to some the extreme
altered states and experiences should be
accompanied by an outer sobriety where
one controls one's actions in speech
while being completely transformed on
the inside others were more allowing of
outer expressions of ecstasy very
famously sufis have been attributed with
ecstatic utterances known as shot while
in altered states as a result of sama
perhaps most famously is the story about
al-halaj who is said to have uttered the
phrase
or i am the truth and bastami who is
quoted as exclaiming subhani glory be to
me
when we read contemporary and later
writings about these utterances we often
see the sufis having an apologetic tone
these are utterances of ineffable
secrets and the person cannot be judged
based on their actions when in a
heightened state many were concerned
about such utterances at the same time
though not so much because what was said
by these mystics was wrong per se but
because they divulged publicly secrets
that should only be kept within a
confined setting of mystical company
as we get into the later middle ages and
as sufism becomes increasingly
widespread and popular as well as more
institutionalized we get more writings
to which we can study and understand how
sama was practiced and the different
attitudes towards it and one conclusion
we have to draw based on those sources
is that sama continued to be a very
widespread and popular practice among
the various sufis in different regions
of the islamic world we have more
references to music from this time both
in some of the great examples of sufi
poetry but also in more scholastic works
with the writings of the monumental
scholar of muhammad al-qazali in
particular his
deen the revival of the religious
sciences as well as other developments
at the time sufism became more widely
accepted as part of a normative
mainstream islam
in the ihe alum
razali not only creates a kind of
theoretical synthesis of sufism
theology and islamic law which became
paradigmatic he also presents us with a
passionate and comprehensive defense of
music and sama in particular he presents
arguments similar to his predecessors
that we have already talked about but he
is even more systematic and presents
theological arguments of his own to
support his claims
for example he famously gives us the
phrase quote whoever says that all music
is prohibited let him also claim that
the songs of birds are prohibited
beautiful sounds and melodies are not a
problem in themselves if so then all
beauty should be as he indicates here
instead it is about the context in which
it is experienced grazali limits the
kinds of instruments that are allowed to
be used in sama sessions only including
those that are not associated with
things like alcohol drinking and taverns
but in general he is a great defender of
sama and music as beneficial to the
muslims who travel on the spiritual path
but not everyone agreed with him perhaps
surprising to some of you the great
andalusian sufi master ibn adabi was not
a fan of sama at all and he condemns the
practice in his great work al-futuhat
al-makiya he says quote they practice
sama as if it was an exercise in
devotion and piety but in fact they are
just people who take religion as a joke
in a game taking advantages of beardless
youths to further their perverse
intentions and villainy the practice
really only serves to satisfy the
appetite of the senses in spite of the
fact that from a legal point of view it
is a perfectly acceptable activity
pretty harsh words to ibn arabi this was
not proper behavior for agnostic even
though he seems to indicate that music
in itself isn't necessarily a problem
according to islamic law he sees it as
completely inappropriate as a religious
sufi practice and this is just to show
you that there's a diversity of opinions
within sufism as well even a great and
one of the most famous super
personalities and thinkers of all time
even arabi was very critical and
strongly against this practice but he
was probably not in the majority at the
time as we see how samar remains a very
popular practice being praised in most
sufi poetry and writings at the time one
of the greatest arabic sufi poets of all
time ibn farid is said to have been a
frequent participant in mystical
gatherings of music and dance but one
story also tells of how he spontaneously
entered an ecstatic state while in a
marketplace quote a group of guards
passed by abner farted while they were
beating clappers and singing upon
hearing these verses ibn farid shouted
out and danced in the marketplace
this attracted a large crowd of people
many of whom fell to the ground in
ecstasy as the guards continued to sing
another writer's recalls how a spiritual
session of sama wasn't considered
complete unless ibn farid attended
and in his own poetry he offers many
praises and descriptions of the beauty
and transformative experiences that are
had while in sama in perhaps his most
famous poem the huge attai al kubra the
old rhyming in the letter ta also known
as nazma soluk the poem of the sufi way
he offers an absolutely beautiful
description of the power of spiritual
audition where he compares it to a
mother singing lullabies to her infant
quote when the infant moans from the
tired swaddling wrap and restlessly
yearns for relief from distress he is
soothed by lullabies and lays a sigh of
the burden that covered him he listens
silently to one who soothes him
the sweet speech makes him forget his
bitter state and remember a secret
whisper of ancient ages
his state makes clear the conditions of
audition sama and confirms the dance to
be free from error for when he burns
with desire from lullabies anxious to
fly to his first abodes he is calm by
his rocking cradle as the hands of the
nurse gently sway it
i have found in gripping rapture when
she is recalled in the chanters tones
and the singer's tunes what a suffering
man feels when he gives up his soul when
the messengers of death come to take him
one finding pain in being driven asunder
is like one pained in rapture yearning
for friends
the soul pitied the body where it first
appeared and my spirit rose to its high
beginnings my spirit soared past the
gates opening to beyond my union where
there is no veil of communion
ibn farid alludes to the spirit's
longing to return to his source in god
the lullaby representing the beauty of
the music that reminds the soul of his
origins and increases his desire for
reunion
as the nurse gently sways him that is as
the sufi sways his body to the music and
the singers chant the name of god the
mystic experiences a spiritual death
where the spirit can soar to a state
beyond all duality
even as he says beyond union of lover
and beloved mystic and god
similarly the andalusian arabic sufi
poet abu hassan ashushtari gave major
importance to music and songs in his
mystical practice
many of his poems in the form of zajal
were songs meant to be sung
stories tell of how shushtari would go
to the markets with his companions and
sing his songs possibly with
instrumental accompaniment to the
regular people in ecstatic sessions
quote when i went towards my objects and
listened to the music my misery became
glory and my poverty riches or quotes oh
fakhri if you would but taste it and
listen to the melodies in the sufi
gatherings you would give up this world
and everything in it and live love
crazed until the day you die
indeed echoing the point made by rozali
earlier shushtari explains in his
resalat al-baghdadia how all forms of
listening can be a devotional act
whether it is in the music of sufi
gatherings or in the singing of birds
quotes listening sama is veneration
speech is veneration as long as what is
said is good sensory experience is
veneration all five senses to study god
can be experienced everywhere at all
times and the perfect devotee is the
person who turns every act and sensory
experience into an act of devotion or
prayer
in all beautiful sounds one can
experience the presence of god the
ritualized practice of sufi sama in this
context becomes like a supercharged way
of audition an audition that can happen
at any time at any place at around this
time in the 12th and 13th centuries we
see the significant development of the
sufi orders a further
institutionalization of sufism into
various tariqas or tarikat in plural
centered often around the teachings of a
singular founder as we will see some of
these orders would implement sama and
music as central parts of their identity
while others would exclude it completely
and these characteristic forms and
expressions of sufi music that developed
in these orders in particular often
survives until today perhaps none is
more famous in this regard than the
persian sufi poet jalaladin rumi and the
mev levia or mevlivi order that was
founded based on him not only is his
most famous poem the song of the read a
direct reference to sama and we'll
return to this poem a little bit later
but it is also said that rumi was a rabb
player himself and his life involves
various stories that showcase his great
love for music and sama in one it is
said that when his spiritual master
shams at tabrizi suddenly disappeared
rumi would start to whirl in an ecstatic
dance
in another story it is told quote once
our master jalaladin said this music is
the creaking of the gates of paradise
whereupon one of the stupid idiots
remarked i do not like the sound of
creaking gates and mavlana that is rumi
answered you hear the doors when they
are being closed but i i hear them when
they are opening
many anecdotes and stories like this
show how greatly rumi loved music and
its powerful effects quote sama was an
activity for the true men of god which
liberated rumi from the all stairways of
self-renunciation and gave him a joyous
vehicle for expressing his mystical
rapture
rumi's close connection to music can be
seen in the characteristic practices of
the mev levy order that he founded or
was founded based on him
it is this order that later developed
the very recognizable form of sama where
the practitioners world in a similar
fashion to stories about the master
himself this has become known as the
whirling dervishes and is a complex and
developed ritual involving musical
suites of several parts and compositions
this whirling is another example of the
kind of dancing movements that often
accompany musical sessions from the
earliest periods and is thought to help
the dervish enter a state of
transcendence and a loss of self to be
united with god
today one will often explain how the
whirling is the most natural movement of
the universe the galaxies revolve and
spinning motions the atoms do the same
as to the planets around the sun of
course rumi wouldn't have known these
scientific facts himself at the time but
whirling was seen as important on a
symbolic level as such a later writer
describes the meanings of the particular
sama practiced by rumi and the mevlavis
at the time quote all the movements
emanating from mystics during the sama
symbolize a point or a truth
for instance whirling is a sign of unity
and this is a station of saints who
stand in that station see the beloved
and the desired everywhere and in all
directions and they attain divine grace
wherever they turn
to jump and to stamp the foot denote two
things the first one denotes the joy of
connecting with the spiritual world
to stamp the foot denotes that the sufi
in that position subordinates his self
and with that strength he treads upon
everything except god
opening the arms denotes several things
the first is related to the joy of the
honor of attainment and to the conferral
of the degree of perfection secondly it
is a victory of the army of inordinate
appetites of the self and the greatest
holy war jihad consists of defeating
these
and that's one of the fascinating things
about sufi music we can see how it is
practiced in all parts of the islamic
world by sufis in all these different
regions but depending on the region
sometimes even depending on the very
order these musical rituals can take
very different forms so the whirling
dervishes is very characteristically
from the mev levy order and the music
employed often takes on a very you can
say ottoman turkish tone because it
developed in that kind of region
[Music]
as another example if we move further to
the east to places like india or the
indian subcontinent generally we see
sufi music and sufi rituals that develop
in a very characteristic style different
from other regions as well in the
chishti order which has been one of the
most popular in this region sama and
music came to play a major role
some of the most significant masters of
this order like nizamuddin auliya were
great advocates of sama and frequently
practiced it one of his own students the
sufi poet and musical composer amir
khuzro is one of the most significant in
this regard he and others like him
developed forms of sufi music that was
unique to this region and had very
strong flavors of indian music culture
genres like kawali came about in this
context which today has been made so
famous by figures like nusrat fatherly
khan
[Music]
in north africa we also see how the
music has a characteristic flavor often
being a combination of arabic and
amazing berber traditions of music here
there is usually a predominance of
percussion instruments and
group chanting but of course there's
diversity too even in instrumentation we
can see differences in the regions of
course because in different regions
different different instruments were
used so in india we see instruments like
the harmonium today being used and
the you know tabla drums and the tampura
perhaps in in the mev levy order we see
instruments like the woods and
instruments that are very
prominent in turkish and anatolian music
in north africa we have other
instruments that are used that are more
frequently used in that particular
region and the music of that region too
so as we can see sufi music developed in
different ways and took different
expressions but the purpose and theory
behind it always remain the same to be
an aid and important practice for
mystical initiates to advance on the
spiritual path and eventually reach the
state of full god remembrance and
self-annihilation through ecstasy
discussions have continued about the
permissibility and appropriateness of
this ritual this practice as well as in
what context and what forms it should be
allowed if at all some of the earliest
writers like junaid for example in
baghdad is said to have counted three
requirements for a sama sessions to be
legitimate
the right place the right time and the
right company but we can also see a
diversity in attitudes about these
various rules and what is required for
it to be permissible by thinkers across
history having different opinions it's
all very diverse and there's always
differing
opinions and people from different sides
arguing about all of these different
questions to some like the very
significant north african sufi abu
madyan sama was a restricted practice he
approved of it but only behind closed
doors and in the company of advanced
sufis in the vidayatan murid he writes
that quote as for the session of
audition or sama it constitutes correct
behavior a point which no one doubts
except the ignorant it is the method of
the saints and the pious
audition is a private thing no one but
its folk should know about it when sufis
are present for ecstatic sessions they
should lock the doors of their homes and
when the food is brought they should
open them again one also sometimes
argued that sama was only something that
was performed as a step on the way to
the higher station of mystical
development but once one had reached
those higher stations one no longer
needed it and it could be discarded
basically quote
sama relates to the spiritual progress
of a muslim mystic or sufi adept in one
of three ways one it may be totally
excluded as inappropriate to islamic
teaching mystical or non-mystical as the
mughal sheikh ahmed sir hindi and his
sub-order the mujadi diya nachspandiya
believed two it may be accepted as a
penultimate stage on the mystical ladder
leading to ontological unity i.e
perfection or three it may be viewed as
the top rung of the ladder itself the
ultimate mystical experience when
properly pursued some had a much more
open attitude to when and how it could
be performed the chishti order is again
a very good example here sama sessions
here were and are often held in public
and around the shrines of important
masters
anyone can basically partake and take
advantage of the music and the
devotional poetry of the ritual and
guide them at least a little bit towards
god
similarly it was argued that sama or
music was not just a step on the way but
could actually be the catalyst and main
parts of the highest forms of mystical
development the very purpose and goal of
the path of union with god
for them music was both the ontological
and the epistemological sin qua non of
islamic mysticism it not only helped the
lover to attain a state of ecstasy in
the presence of the beloved but it
itself was integral to the ecstatic
moment if you go to india or pakistan
sufi music can easily be heard in the
form of khawali singing near the shrines
of different masters from the chishti
order for example like nizamuddin aliyah
chishti or amir
the latter of which you know his poetry
is so popular that the
the words that you're hearing these sufi
sing is most likely his own words from
his poetry the world of sufi music and
its diversity is a fascinating thing
wherever you travel in the islamic world
you can find different variants and
expressions of this
deep tradition whether you are in
morocco in turkey in iran in india or in
sudan all these different regions and
cultures have their own spin on this
practice but as we said earlier it
always has the same function of being an
aid on the spiritual path towards
intimacy with god and this very deep
tradition of sufi music has been very
significant not only for the development
of musuvi music in itself and for the
practices of the sufis but also for the
development of music in general in the
islamic world especially from the later
middle ages when sufism became
mainstream and into the modern period
sufi composers were integral to the
development of various strands of arabic
persian turkish and indian music
in the ottoman empire for example the
mev levy order of rumi received great
supports from the sultans and were often
close with the courts the masters and
composers of the mev levy order were
often also composers of secular court
music and the two genres greatly
influenced each other some of the most
noteworthy and form-giving compositions
of the ottoman and turkish repertoire
come from sufi composers from the mev
levy and genvity orders similarly in
places like north africa we see how sufi
music becomes very important for this
scene music that was composed and
performed were often based on poems by
great sufi personalities and the
situation today is quite fascinating as
well as you might know sufism is not as
widespread or popular as it was earlier
in history and this means also that sama
practices aren't as prevalent as they
used to be but sufi music still is of
course very strong in many ways and it
has developed into new forms and taken
new avenues of expression
remember what we said in the beginning
we are defining sufi music more broadly
here is not just including the more
ritualized practice oriented forms of
this tradition the more traditional
forms of sufi sama sessions exist today
still of course the chishti sufis will
still still sing hawali music at the
shrines of the great masters the mev
levy order still has their whirling
dervishes both as a legitimate spiritual
practice but also even as a kind of
terrorist attraction as i'm sure many of
you have seen if you visit a place like
morocco you can still find sufi groups
who gather for sessions of both vicar
and sama
some in private but others also in
public like for example in the very
characteristic and colorful performances
of the isawaya sufi order in sudan
followers of the qatari order can be
seen performing a unique kind of vicar
or
you could argue a kind of sama involving
dancing and in egypt there are huge
gatherings for different maulid
celebrations where sufi saints are
celebrated great traditions like the
molead of the egyptian sufi saint ahmed
al-badawi will involve huge gatherings
of people engaged in ecstatic audition
to poems being sung with complex musical
accompaniments with modern equipment so
clearly sama in its more traditional
form is still alive and well and
continues to develop and evolve but sufi
music is more broad than this as well
and in the last few decades especially
we have seen an increase in what we
could call a more
commercialized form of sufi music i have
already mentioned nusrat fatih khan who
did figure in a traditional koali
environment most of the time but also
record those traditional songs on albums
and at musical festivals sort of
straddling the line between the modern
and the traditional he made kowali thus
central asian sufi music popular to a
worldwide audience and this is still
carried forward by artists like abita
praveen but others are seemingly
completely divorced from its ritualized
aspects performing what we could call
art music but which still figures within
a sufi framework because of the themes
involved the senegalese singer yosondur
who is from a country where sufism is
especially widespread released an album
called santa yala in 2004 which was
released as egypt internationally that
is essentially traditionally infused pop
music but with lyrical themes
exclusively about sufism and the
important figures of the muradia and
tijania sufi orders this is quite a
common thing in the pop music scene in
west africa with artists like baba mal
also incorporating sufi themes in his
lyrics and in west africa there is a
strong tradition of griot singers which
are
singers who will sing devotional songs
to various sufi sheikhs and marabouts or
just important
leaders or figures generally a tradition
that i've had the privilege of
experiencing first hand
[Music]
hey
[Music]
in iran one is really and understandably
proud of the great tradition of persian
sufi poets and there is a flourishing
musical scene there which often
explicitly references this tradition
singers like shahada naziri and the
recently passed muhammad reza shajarian
have become celebrated artists around
the world while singing songs based on
the poetry of rumi hafez and many others
and with music that is heavily rooted in
the traditions of sufism even more
recently the british based artist and
composer sami yusuf has done some really
amazing work to gather interpret and
perform classic sufi poetry and music
from different cultures and regions in
an accessible way through ambitious
concerts and recordings add to this the
many experimentations and the appearance
of genres like sufi rock and sufi trans
which
while perhaps staying true to their
traditional
connection with
ecstatic states does not feature things
like sufi poetry a lot of time and more
kind of figures within a general
vibe a sufi vibe or featuring
sufi
associated instrumentation for example
as you can tell then sufi music in a
general sense has spread into various
different contexts genres and regions of
the world and people really love this
stuff there are festivals arranged like
the fez festival of world sacred music
which is often heavily focused on the
sufi tradition in particular and other
such developments which show that
whether in its traditional ritualized
form or not sufi music is certainly here
to stay
the incredibly colorful stories about
the effects of music and sama on its
practitioners indicate the incredible
power that it has to affect the human
being
but why did it have this effect how did
and do the sufi's view music and its
role in a more from from a metaphysical
and
perhaps psychological perspective
this is another treasure trove of
fascinating stuff to explore the power
of music was realized basically
universally both by its supporters and
the tractors we see how many of the
early islamic philosophers wrote many
works on music and often connected it to
various cosmological and metaphysical
ideas thinkers like al-kindi al-farabi
and ibn cena loved music they realized
the medical and therapeutic use of music
and often employed it as treatment for
various physical and mental ailments a
point often pointed out by the sufi
writers to argue for its permissibility
and use music is harmony and is strongly
connected to mathematics and the spheres
of the heavens according to these
philosophers there's a great section in
the epistle of the echuana safa the
brethren of purity who write that quote
you should know dear brother may god age
you and us with a spirit of his that in
every manual craft the matter or hyula
dealt with consists of naturally
occurring material and that all its
products are physical forms
the exception is music for the matter it
deals with consists entirely of
spiritual substances namely the souls of
those who listen to it
the musician is he or she who shapes and
works with the souls of other human
beings and animals
they also write quotes the tones
produced by the movements of the
musician reminds the individual souls
that are in the world of generation and
corruption of the joy of the world of
the celestial spheres just as the tones
produced by the movements of the
celestial spheres and the heavenly
bodies remind the souls that are there
of the joy of the world of spirits
in other words the harmony and beauty of
music reminds the soul of the harmony
and beauty of the celestial world and
the divine realm that many sufis would
echo similar sentiments in the salah of
khoshairi which we have already quoted
previously he retells a story quote i
heard al-junaid say when someone asked
him why is a man usually quiet but
becomes agitated when he hears music
he junaid answered god most high
addressed disembodied human souls during
the primordial act saying am i not your
lord they answered yes we testify and
the spirits of human beings fully absorb
the sound of these words so whenever
they listen to music the remembrance of
that original act of hearing agitates
them here junaid is connecting the
listening to and effects of music with
quranic principles the primordial
covenant when god creates the world and
asks am i not your lord becomes the
original music of our spiritual origin
and anytime we hear beautiful music in
the sensible world we are reminded of
this original foundation
this idea of music as remembrance a form
of vikr becomes a recurring theme
in rumi's masterwork of poetry the mas
navi he opens the entire thing with the
poem that has become known as the song
of the reed
listen to the reed and the tale it tells
how it sings of separation
ever since they cut me from the weed bed
my whale has caused men and women to
weep
i want a heart that is torn open with
longing so that i might share the pain
of this love
whoever has been parted from his source
longs to return to that state of union
these are just the opening lines but it
already indicates the meaning rumi is
talking about the wailing or sound of
the reed flute the nay which has been an
important instrument and symbol in sufi
music and how this sad yet beautiful
sound is a metaphor for the longing of
the human soul to return to its source
in god when the person hears the
melodies of the nay that melody mirrors
the longing of the soul and pushes it
towards its desire for union there is
also a great story involving ali ibn abi
talib this story tells of how the
prophet muhammad once told ali the most
exalted and deepest secrets of reality
in confidence and made ali promise to
never tell another person the secret ali
was true to his word but this secret was
so amazing that he could not contain
himself he just couldn't keep it inside
so he went in secret to a little lake
and whispered the secret into the reed
bed which absorbed it into its own being
so when we hear the beautiful music of
the nay the read flute we are in some
way hearing that secret that the prophet
told ali i just love this story
and the sound of the instrument also
becomes a metaphor for another aspect of
the human condition and the relationship
between god and creation just as the nay
requires the player to blow into it to
give it life and the drum requires a
hand that caresses it or a loot needs
fingers that pluck it so human beings or
anything in creation is constantly given
life by the breath of god we are the
sounds and instruments played by god
if we want to find poetic goddesses
about sama and music and its symbolic
metaphysical function there is a lot of
stuff to draw from
we already saw the earlier examples from
ibn farid and study and rumi is an
especially great point of reference
in another poem he writes quote
the wise men tell us that we take these
tunes from the turning of celestial
spheres
these sounds are revolutions of the
skies that man composes with his liar
and throat we all were parts of adam at
one time in paradise we all have heard
these tunes
though clay and water fill us up with
doubts we still remember something of
those songs
and so like food sama sustains god's
lovers within its harmonies the mind's
composed imagination draws its
inspiration takes its shape within this
hue and cry
the huge importance and love rumi shows
towards sama is apparent not only in the
poetry itself but in the practice of
sama as it developed in the medley order
characterized by the whirling motion
that he was taught by shamsa tabrizi and
the above poem mentions how the music
and movement of the whirling dervish
mirrors the turning of the heavens and
the spheres
in many of these poems and descriptions
music becomes an essential component of
reality and creation
rumi again here provides one of the most
beautiful visions of reality and
creation i can think of much like junaid
he views the originating moment when god
asked allah become am i not your lord as
essentially a musical one
these words are a musical sound a melody
to which non-being responds by beginning
to dance to whirl and from this dance is
created all of the universe every atom
every galaxy every flower and animal all
of them come to be and move in a
constant dance to the melody of the
divine creative music
it's absolutely breathtaking imagery and
here the earthly sama or music becomes a
micro version of the most essential
movements of the universe itself a
mirroring of the divine order
in the greatest sheikh the andalusian
ibn arabi we get a similar idea he
conceives of the creation and continues
maintaining of the world as a
relationship of speaking and hearing or
listening the originating command
or be is a kind of sound or speech a
non-sensible one of course to which
creation responds by listening
he refers to this as a sama al-mutlaq
absolute sama and he sees it as an
essential part of how reality works
this sama isn't musical as in the case
of rumi but sensible music can be seen
as a part or mode of this wider absolute
listening and ibn arabi in general is
very important for our next point or
perspective on these spiritual and
metaphysical aspects of music as we saw
earlier he himself was very much hostile
to the practice but his wider ideas
provide us and other mystics with a
perfect mystical foundation to build on
the main philosophical or theological
position that ibn arabi and his
followers are associated with is the
doctrine of
or the unity or oneness of being ibn
arabi himself never used this term but
it became a very influential theoretical
expression of sufi metaphysics around
the world after him in the so-called
unity of being ibn arabi essentially
argues that there is only one reality
reality itself or al-haq which is god
god or the one is all there is and
everything quote other than god is
simply non-being based on the hadith
kudzi that states i was a hidden
treasure and i loved to be known so i
created the world that i might be known
he sees all of creation as the
continuous self-disclosure or
manifestation of god's infinite
attributes like in a mirror everything
we see everything we experience is a
mirror showing a particular reflection
of god's attributes like the colors of
the rainbow being an illusory diversity
hiding the inner unity of the white
light
thus there is nothing but god according
to bin adabi but god is also utterly
transcendent and different from the
world the world is god and not god
all existence in itself is god because
god is being itself and there is only
one being and all multiplicity is a
refraction or projection of his infinite
oneness into a multiplicity that
reflects him back at himself in a
limited form
this is a very simplified explanation
and if you want to know more about eben
adams and his doctrine i suggest you
watch my full video on that topic what
is important for us here is the idea
that all things are reflections of god's
attributes so that there is quote
nothing which is not an aspect of god or
in which god can be contemplated or
experienced in an indirect form
when god is experienced the mystic
realizes that there is only one
experiencer experiencing himself in a
mirror and duality then falls apart as
the christian mystic master eckhart said
the i with which i see god is the same
eye with which god sees me or in ibn
arabi's own words quote he is a mirror
for your vision of yourself and you are
his mirror for his vision of the names
or attributes which are none other than
himself and the manifestation of their
determinations
but what does this have to do with music
well music is a thing that you
experience after all and so i think you
can kind of see where i'm going with
this but let's go even deeper than that
when the very famous philosopher ibn
cena or avicenna wrote about beauty what
beauty itself is he followed in the line
of aristotle
in history
the treatise on love he essentially
defines beauty as that which is
harmonious quote both the rational and
the animal soul the latter by reason of
its proximity to the former invariably
love what has beauty of order
composition and harmony as for example
harmonious sounds harmoniously blended
tastes of well-prepared dishes and such
like
it recognizes that the closer thing is
to the first object of love the more
steadfast it is in its order and the
more beautiful in its harmony and what
follows it results there from vis-a-vis
harmony and agreement whereas on the
contrary the more remote a thing is from
it the near is it to multiplicity and
such characteristics as follow it
contrast and disharmony
beauty results from harmony and harmony
is associated with oneness thus closer
to god whereas disharmony is
multiplicity
and what is music if not harmony thus we
have found a theoretical foundation for
why music is beautiful
music is harmony and thus music is
beauty
but to thinkers like eben arabi there is
only one beauty god is the beautiful not
just in the sense that he has that
quality but in the sense that he is
beauty essentially there is no beauty
but him just as there is no reality but
him all beauty or harmony that we
experience in the world is but a tiny
reflection of beauty itself
god
so now we have taken this as far as it
can possibly go
based on the ideas of an arabi and
music is no longer just a reminder of
higher realities or the human soul's
origin in the divine womb
no longer is it just a beautiful
metaphor for the creation of the world
now to experience the beauty of music in
an act of sama is to experience god
himself it is to experience the absolute
in itself not fully of course but a
glimpse of the divine reality and thus a
glimpse into one's own most inner
essence and identity
try thinking of that next time you hear
a good song
to finish off it would be a disservice
if we didn't also discuss the 20th
century sufi figure in nayat khan a
master of the chishti order from india
and an accomplished musician himself
inayat khan was one of the first and
most important sufis to travel to the
west and introduce the tradition here
he did so through lectures and musical
concerts and in those lectures he would
often talk about the importance of an
exalted nature of music and sound there
is even a book based on those lectures
and writings called the mysticism of
sound and music which deals exclusively
with this topic in this book khan picks
up on many of the ideas that have
already been discussed by earlier sufis
but also expanded the theoretical and
cosmological significance of music he
also wasn't afraid to incorporate
teachings on music from other religious
traditions like hinduism universalist in
scope as he was
he mirrors the theory based on the unity
of being by saying quote music is
nothing less than the picture of the
beloved
and based on earlier president as well
as more up-to-date scientific theories
of his time he argues that the whole
world is essentially music quote music
is the beginning and end of the universe
all actions and movements made in the
visible and invisible world are musical
that is they are made up of vibrations
creation begins with the activity of
consciousness which may be called
vibration and every vibration starting
its original source is the same
differing only in its tone and rhythm
caused by a greater or lesser degree of
force behind it inayat khan argues that
at its deepest level the universe is
made up of vibration and music and sound
is after all just that vibrations so the
universe is just a large elaborate
musical composition with harmony in the
movements of the heavens and the way
everything is intricately structured
rhythm in the way that we move for
example we can't walk without rhythm and
in the workings of things
music is all around us we can find
rhythm in basically anything and we can
see harmony in every corner of the
universe
today the scientific theory known as
string theory is one of the most popular
for explaining the most inner workings
of the universe in which everything is
thought of as vibrating strings like on
a guitar
the ideas being put forth by an ayat
khan are not that far off from this
quote when we pay attention to nature's
music we find that everything on the
earth contributes to its harmony
the trees joyously wave their branches
and rhythm with the wind the sound of
the sea the murmuring of the breeze the
whistling of the wind through the rocks
hills and mountains the flash of the
lightning and the crash of the thunder
the harmony of the sun and the moon the
movements of the stars and planets
the blossoming of the flower the fading
of the leaf the regular alternation of
morning noon and night all revealed to
the seer the music of nature
so clearly there are many ways that one
can view music from a theoretical
perspective and i've only gone through a
few examples here but important to
remember is that the use of music and
the sama sessions of the sufis have
historically primarily been a practical
thing right so the purpose of these
practices were to
help the sufi adept
on the path towards intimacy with god
help him on the spiritual path
essentially theorizing about the
metaphysics or cosmological role of
music in reality or in the world was
only of interest to a few select
very philosophically minded sufis in
history but they can still inform and
they do inform the more practically
oriented sufis and the way that they
conceive of these practices from a more
metaphysical perspective and can also of
course inspire a lot of us today who
have a similar kind of relationship to
music perhaps this has obviously been a
very long episode but i hope you find
this topic as interesting as i do there
is so much to cover and as is always the
case but really there is so much else to
go through as well so many things that i
had to leave out
and that just wouldn't fit into this
video i would go on for hours and hours
but hopefully now you can see how deep
of a tradition sufi music is both in its
traditional ritualized forms but also in
the more contemporary ways that it
expresses itself in in art music and in
different
genres and ways across the globe it has
not only been an important part of
sufism or tasawaf historically but also
a very valuable factor in the
development of music in the islamic
world more generally
as well as in the artistic heritage of
the world
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you